luca you were watching that shot and and
even you were surprised
what were the emotions during that final
play and
what you have now it's a lot of emotions
you know we have amazing group of guys
you know
uh i know clippers is one of the best
teams in the league but you know we show
our heart that we can fight and i mean
it's very emotional
yeah you were down 21. kristoff's is a
late scratch
how would you describe just the energy
it took to pull this one out
in ot i mean it's unbelievable you know
the way the team fights you know
cape is a big piece and you know uh
his knees been bothering him it's i know
i know he feels really bad because you
know
he wasn't able being to be in the in the
court
but you know we need him he's going to
be back and you know i just i just love
this team
a 42 point triple double your coach
called you a bad boy
a gamer just an all-around tough guy
how if at all did your ankle affect you
in this performance i mean
i think it's emotions like i said before
you know the adrenaline
this morning i wasn't feeling very good
you know but as soon as i stepped on the
court i knew i could go
and you know my teammates helped me a
lot uh yesterday
the staff the people that don't that you
don't hear their names you know they did
an amazing job with me
they'll be with me the whole day and
that's that's the result we get
you talked about the talent of this
clippers team you're now
tied up at two games a piece what type
of confidence does this team have now
pulling out this win in this fashion i
mean we have confidence since the
beginning you know
obviously it's confidence even more now
but we have constants as
uh from the beginning uh like i said in
one interview if you don't believe you
shouldn't be here
but we believe since the beginning and
we're here thai tutu
congratulations thank you